hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
franz fanon was among other things a
practicing
psychoanalyst and so it's no surprise
that within his work black skin
white mask psychoanalysis would assume
a real centrality of of place
in an approach and in complex ways
that we're going to explore here he
tells us
that the focus of the work in general
and i think this is
pretty much dead on is a
psychoanalytical interpretation
of what he calls the black problem which
itself is quite complex it's not
something
you can frame in just a sentence or two
although he does give you a number of
nice
pithy uh exemplifications of this
in in the process of the work but those
are launching points
rather than full formulations of the
the problem or the issue that he's
working at
and early on in the work he says that
here we go i have to say certain things
the analysis
i'm undertaking is psychological in
spite of this it is apparent to me
that the effect of dis alienation so
that's that's one of the goals right
there
the dis alienation of the black person
entails an immediate recognition of
social and economic realities and so
this is going to be something really
central
to his approach you cannot have a
psychoanalysis
that ignores history that ignores
the way society is set up that ignores
economic realities
and how economics is not a you know pure
domain
but intrudes into all these other
domains as well so he goes on and he
says
if there is an inferiority complex it is
the outcome
of a double process primarily economic
subsequently the internalization or
better the epidermalization
meaning going under the skin of this
inferiority so you know that that is
quite good he also calls this a
sociodiagnostic
as well and if you look at the work as a
whole
there's actually two chapters that are
devoted specifically to
examining psychoanalytic
interpretations diagnoses things like
that the
chapter 4 so-called dependency complex
of colonized people
and then there's actually a chapter
chapter 6 the negro in psychopathology
but also in chapter 7 about half of the
chapters devoted to considering
adler's ego psychology so
it's it's really quite important here he
is engaging in
critiques of other psychoanalytic
theorists
and there are a few passages i thought
would be good to bring
out into the fore and when we say
critique a lot of people interpret this
word critique
as like you're going to smash something
and knock it down
no critiques are careful if it's not
careful it's not a critique
it's just complaining right and what a
critique is doing is saying okay
this part over here this actually seems
pretty dead on
this part over here it's it's not really
working
and you could also go into like you know
what are the conditions of the
possibility of doing this
sort of transcendental critique there's
a lot of different ways to critique
critique is not primarily aimed at being
negative and just disrupting matters
so he says here we go psychoanalytic
schools have studied the neurotic
reactions that arise among certain
groups
in certain areas of civilization in
response to the requirements of
dialectic
what does that mean we'll talk about
that in a moment one should investigate
the extent to which the conclusions of
freud or of adler
can be applied to the effort to
understand the man of color's
view of the world can
somebody like freud can somebody like
adler who are
conscious of colonialism taking place
who know
about you know effectively
becoming multicultural societies you
know
at the time let's say adler is working
uh you know
you could say that there's much more
hierarchy than there is
is today uh in terms of of you know how
people are
treated and categorized and segregated
but you know they don't really have as
much to say about the issue now
fanon doesn't think that just not being
black or not having come from a
particular
place makes it impossible for you to
enter into the world of other people's
lived experiences as a matter of fact he
clarifies in the work that
it is actually possible to go into other
people's lived experiences
but it takes work and he thinks that
that freud and adler
haven't actually managed to do that a
little bit later on
in the work he brings jung in there as
well he says
the reason i'm calling this chapter the
negro in psychopathology
well aware that freud and adler and even
the cosmic jung
did not think of the negro in all their
investigations
and then he also says they were quite
right not to have
because maybe their theories didn't
apply as well you know
he gives us an example the oedipus
complex not everybody has an oedipus
complex
you know freud thought everybody did and
others following after him try to
generalize it
lacan by the way who he's going to bring
up a little bit later
in some of his seminars will suggest
that the oedipus complex is really a
master wester
a matter rather of western thought
and and organization and the west might
even be able to get rid of it as well
in in some way down the line that it
doesn't apply
universally so let's talk about the
the particular theorists that he brings
up and
what he gets out of them and what he
says they they're missing out on so
freud of course
you know father of psycho analysis he
credits freud
for having focused on what he calls the
individual factor and this is this is
quite important because
it's not as if psychology or even
psychotherapy wasn't being carried out
before
freud right it was going on for
quite a long time there was even a
profession of people called alienists to
deal with
those who were deemed insane and so
freud is actually reacting against an
entire
uh tendency as founded says he says
this is a constitutionalist tendency
what is a constitutionalist tendency it
says
well you know people are reacting
in sort of normal or abnormal ways
because of the constitutions
that they have that is the way that in
which their body is put together it
could be temperaments right it could be
tied in with all sorts of
different things and maybe you can
modify it maybe you can't modify
it and freud paid attention to the
individual
patient now if you read freud's case
histories
sometimes you're like well he paid
attention to what he wanted to pay
attention to
there's a lot of problems with that but
this focus on the individual factor
very important he says freud insisted
the individual factor be taken into
account through psychoanalysis he's
substituted for a phylogenetic theory
the ontogenetic perspective and then he
says
this is fun it will be seen that the
black man's alienation is not however
an individual question beside philo
jenny and anto jenny
stands sociogeny and this is why he
talks about a socio-diagnostic so
freud is good for focusing on the
individual factor which is being left
out
and he also focuses on the experience
and repression
of trauma but the the framework that he
sets up is too restrictive
for examining the kinds of subjects that
that fun home thinks
is vital not just important but vital
for dealing with this alienation so he
goes on and he says
this is deep in the work
he's talking about about freud and the
the experience
of trauma right he says that this is
something we can we can learn from him
and that you know these things are
supposed to occur
within the family but the problem is
and he's saying this in the negro path
psychopathology
the characteristics of the family are
projected onto the social
environment and that's not being
adequately taken into account
by freud so there's this focus on family
dynamics that's good
you know uh the family is a place in
which things are being played out right
um on the unconscious that's that's an
important realization now what exactly
the unconscious is going to be
okay different theorists have different
ways of dealing with it is something
purely individual is it something that
is
you know across cultures the collective
unconscious
is it somewhere in between is it the
unconscious structured as a language
okay we can put that aside then we move
on to manoni
and fanon devotes an entire
chapter to manoni's book
uh prospe prospero and caliban right
which is about
the colonial mindset and and all the
issues that are going on
and uh manoni spent a lot of time in
madagascar
and um funona actually says this is a
dangerous book
it's dangerous because it it is partly
right but also
in many respects deeply wrong and manoni
postulated a dependency complex
among colonized people using madagascar
as
a prime example so the idea behind the
dependency complex is that
the reason why some people have been
colonized why some people have been
subordinated
is that within them as a people
and as individuals there is this you
could call it weakness this
this willingness to be dominated by
another
and obviously this is something that is
like you say postulated rather than
something that is
revealed and um
fanon thinks that this is this is quite
wrong this is the
uh sort of putting the cart before the
horse
in explanation it's not really
explaining anything
and he says that you know if you look at
all of these these relations between
people
how did this actually play itself
out he says not all people says not all
peoples can be colonized only those who
experience this need
for dependency wherever europeans have
founded colonies of the type we're
considering
it can safely be said that their coming
was unconsciously expected
even desired by the future subject
people
and you know fanon goes and says well
there's plenty of other explanations for
this you know it could be that the
europeans just came in and dominated the
place
it could be that they took advantage of
the hospitality
that was being offered them it could be
that they
uh you know misrepresented what was
going on
so he's you know saying that manoni is
really
failing to take stock of of the racism
that is developing and driving this and
he's got two
good passages here discussing this he
says
monony says that colonial exploitation
is not the same as other forms of
exploitation and colonial racialism
is different from other kinds of
racialism he speaks a phenomenology of
psychoanalysis
we would be happier if these terms have
been if they'd taken on a more concrete
quality for him and here's where fanon
lays his hand on the table all forms of
exploitation resemble one another
colonial racism is no different than any
other kind of racism
it's not caused by a dependency complex
that then justifies it
it's caused by the fact that people are
imposing things and he goes on and he
says a little bit later on
i begin to suffer from not being a white
man to the degree that the white man
imposes discrimination on me makes me a
colonized native robs me of all worth
all individuality tells me i'm a
parasite in the world that i must bring
myself as quickly as possible and to
step with the white world
that i'm a brute beast my people and i
are like a walking dung heap that
disgustingly fertilizes sweet sugar cane
and silky cotton
that i have no use in the world he says
then i will
quite simply try to make myself white
that is i will compel
the white man to acknowledge that i'm
human menoni will counter you cannot do
it because in your depth there's a
dependency complex
and so you know fanon is saying okay
there might be a dependency complex
but that's not the cause that's the
effect of all of this other stuff that's
going on
so minoni you've like totally got things
backwards
and you know this is often the case with
psychoanalysis isn't it
he's also got a great example there of
the interpretation of dreams
you know freudian psychoanalysis big
stress on dream interpretation
fanon himself thinks that this is quite
useful and does it with his own patience
but um you got to be careful in how
you're interpreting the dream right
so he's got some examples here
of of uh people from madagascar
who are talking about these scary dreams
and experiences that they're having
uh many of the whom are are children and
he says
um you know who who is the black bull do
we have to go to some sort of archetype
to do it no these are senegalese
soldiers who are actually imposing the
french
you know uh colonial government's
desires upon these people and engaging
in horrible atrocities
you know it's it's quite natural that
the things from our lived experience
take place in our dreams we don't have
to go to some crazy psychoanalytic
you know uh explanation of it that
ignores the fact of living in a racist
society
right so manoni is is going to be
you know viewed as as a quite off-base
but revealing some things to us
he also talks about jacques khan manoni
and lacan by the way have a connection
to each other
uh in france down the line so
the he credits with attacking the idea
of the constitutional
uh as freud did uh himself
and that's that's a good thing on on his
view
this notion that uh you know human
beings here we go
in the domain of psychoanalysis as in
that of uh
psych philosophy the organic or
constitutional is a myth
only for him who can go beyond it you
know we we are kind of stuck with it
he says earlier i referred to jacques
lacan it was not by accident in his
thesis
he violently attacked the idea of the
constitutional and then he says
apparently i'm departing from his
conclusions but my dissent will be
understood that
when that when one recalls that for the
idea of the constitutional
as it is understood by the french school
i am substituting
the idea of structure embracing
unconscious
psychic life as we're able to know it in
part especially in the form of
repression and inhibition
insofar as these elements take an active
part in the organization peculiar to
each
psychic individuality and here he quotes
goo who we're going to look at a little
bit later
so you know he's saying lacan is is
useful in some respects he also thinks
that lacombe
goes too far into buying into and
defending
the oedipus complex he's got a footnote
here
and he says dr lecon talks about the
abundance of the oedipus complex
but even if the young boy has to kill
his father it's still necessary the
father
to accept being killed and you know he
says listen
the oedipus complex i'm not sure
that this really works and then he says
the collapse of moral values in france
after the war was perhaps the result of
the defeat of that moral being
which the nation represented we know
what such traumatizations
traumatisms on the family level may
produce so you know
the oedipus complex part of you could
say freudian orthodoxy
not particularly helpful to try to
put out onto all the rest of the world
lacan is kind of an equivocal character
when it comes to this
there's also a really long interesting
discussion in a footnote that spans
several pages
of lacan's mirror stage
ideas which i'm just going to mention
here and not try to go into depth about
because that's that's kind of a tricky
concept and fanon doesn't
doesn't do all that much with it except
to note that when certain experiments
are carried out on
certain people like antillians they
the other who's projected doesn't have
color that is neither black nor
nor white so that's interesting jung he
brings up as well
and he says that jung is actually
quite helpful with with one idea at
least that of the collective
unconsciousness
but then he gets it uh quite wrong
and understandably so so he says
here this is talking about the you know
freudian
neuroses coming from particular
traumas and experiences he says what do
we see in the case of the black man
unless we make use of that frightening
postulate which so destroys our balance
offered by jung
the collective unconscious we can
understand absolutely nothing
we can't just focus on the individual we
do have to think about
people as belonging to collectivities
which would have their own
unconsciousness
and you know by the way this is not so
radically
different than lacan the unconscious is
structured like a language you don't
have your own private language
you belong to an open-ended language
very different than jung's
collective unconscious though so he says
how
is one to a drama is enacted every day
in colonized countries
um and and he talks about how how this
drama plays out
how do you explain this but then he says
that
jung has effectively
misappropriated this
idea and misapplied it to
colonized peoples so here we go
it says um i naturally found myself
on the threshold of union psychology
european civilization
is characterized by the presence at the
heart of which
jung calls the collective unconscious of
an archetype an expression of the bad
instincts
of the darkness inherent in every ego of
the uncivilized savage the negro who
slumbers in
every white man and jung claims to have
found in uncivilized people's the same
psychic structure
his diagram portrays so there's two
claims being made there
in european civilization according to
jung there's this dark
figure and archetype that is is within
all of us
and we all have to repress it and it's
exemplified in
the african negro right and then it's
also
found in every other culture as well
presumably including those of africa
this this dark
figure and then he and then he says
personally i think
jung has deceived himself in all the
people that he has known
whether the pueblo indians of arizona or
the negros of kenya and british east
africa
all of these have had more or less
traumatic contacts with the white man
and so that is something that jung
doesn't take account of he says the
collective unconscious
without our having to fall back on the
genes is purely and simply
the sum of prejudices myths
collective attitudes of a given
group the collective unconsciousness is
not something
that is just built in
and plays itself out it is something
extremely cultural
which means it's also historical right
it has
a in existence to it that develops
within time
a little bit further he says on the
level of philosophical discussion
we would be bringing up the old problem
of instinct and habit instinct which is
inborn
invariable specific habit which is
acquired on this level one would have to
only demonstrate
jung is confused instinct and habit
so you know that's that's an important
charge
right there he goes on a little bit
further and he's talking about
jung identifying the foreign with the
obscure with the tendency to
evil uh this being part particularly
problematic and then he goes a little
bit further out and he says
the collective unconscious is not
dependent on cerebral
heredity it is the result of what i call
the unreflected
imposition of a culture
and he gives an example here there's no
reason to be surprised when an antillean
exposed to waking dream therapy
relives the same fantasies as a european
it is because the antillean partakes of
the same collective unconsciousness
as the european and not
you know of africans but that could all
change
you know if it is not simply biological
or
race-based or genetic or anything like
this
that it is cultural then then jung would
be
a bit off-base we can shift gears and
talk about adler
adler focused very much on individual
psychology
and early on in the work uh fanon says
that this is uh
quite useful and helpful um
he thinks that uh adler uh is
is getting us towards something that can
be
of use but then uh he he talks about
in this entire section on adler towards
the end
in the second to last chapter
adler was postulating this desire for
recognition for um
being essentially seen as oneself
as one wants to be by the other and so
here's this long passage that that
phenomenon quotes
from whatever direction one approaches
the analysis of abnormal psychogenic
conditions one
soon finds oneself in the presence of
the following phenomenon
the whole picture of the neurosis as
well as its all of its symptoms emerges
as
under the influence of some final goal
indeed as projections of this goal
one can ascribe the character of a
formative cause to this final goal the
quality of a principle of orientation
it goes on he says try to find the
meaning and direction of unhealthy
manifestations you come to face to face
with a chaotic throng
of tendencies impulses weaknesses
anomalies but
if we accept the hypothesis of a final
goal or causal finality we see the
shadows dissolve at once and we can read
the soul of the patient
like the pages of a book so we can
totally understand
what's going on with the patient and um
fanon goes on to say it's on the basis
of similar theoretical positions that in
general
the most stupendous frauds of our period
are constructed so you know
that's not really an endorsement of
adler there
now is it and he says so you know we
have to be pretty careful
in doing these things not because
adler's actually wrong about us
desiring what we desire but he's not
understanding the context the social
context the racial context
in which it has been placed he's missing
the fundamental
structure of of things and
so he goes on and he he talks about you
know
the other and how we we engage with the
other and about narcissism
let's let's move ahead though he says
here the difficulties begin
in effect adler has created a psychology
of the individual
we've seen that the feeling of
inferiority is
and characteristic of the antilleans it
is not ju
just this or that in tillian who
embodies the neurotic formation
but all antilians antillean society is
an erotic society
a society of comparison and so he says
that the martinique and
one of the particular islands in the
antilles
is and is not a neurotic if we were
strict in applying the conclusions of
the adlerian school
we should say the negro is seeking to
protest against the inferiority he feels
but now fenon adds an important word
here historically
since in all periods the negro has been
an inferior he attempts to react with a
superiority complex
and this doesn't doesn't really work out
and he's got this interesting
um reworking uh of adler
he says that the martinican does not
compare himself with the white man as
father leader god he compares himself
with his fellow against the pattern of
the white man
so instead of the adlerian schema of the
ego
greater than the other superiority is
response to inferiority complex
he says we have to have a triadic
relation which has the white
above and then ego different from the
other and he says the adlerian
comparison embraces two terms
it's polarized by the ego the antillean
comparison is surmounted by a third time
term its governing fiction is not
personal but social
so this is really you know quite an
excellent way of reformulating things
we're not going to get rid of adler
altogether
we're not going to throw his insights
completely away we're going to rework
them
and this is also what's happening in
terms of uh jermaine gu
uh who talks about pre-edible
abandonment neurosis
um and this is this is uh sketched out
as
as i mentioned she's she cited earlier
in the work um
here we go gu analyzes two types the
first of which seems to illustrate the
plight of this
author jean-venus it is this tripod the
anguish
created by every abandonment the
aggression to which it gives rise
and the devaluation itself that flows
out of it that supports the whole
symptom
symptomology of this neurosis now
the the issue however is is the news
really representative of what's going on
or is he kind of you know an outlier and
and fanon
says that venus is a neurotic his color
is only an
attempt to explain his psychic structure
if this objective difference had not
existed he would have manufactured it
out of nothing
he is one of those intellectuals to try
to take a position solely on the level
of ideas
skipping down a little bit he says i
contend jean vanus represents not an
example of black white
relations but a certain mode of behavior
in a neurotic
who by coincidence is black and so that
that line
is not going to be all that useful
although that doesn't mean we have to
throw out q
so what does fanon then bring to the
picture
and i'm not going to give you everything
you should read the book itself
but there are a few particularly
important
sections and passages where he he sets
things up
he talks about making things conscious
right he says
as as a psychoanalytic practitioner my
goal is to make things conscious
my patient is suffering from an
inferiority complex
if he's overwhelmed to such a degree by
the wish to be white it's because he
lives in a society that makes this
possible so what we have to do then is
help my patient become conscious of his
unconscious
and abandon his attempts at a
hallucinatory
whitening but that's the individual part
also to act in the direction of a change
in the social structure
in other words the black man should no
longer be confronted by the dilemma turn
white or disappear
but he should be able to take cognizance
of a possibility of
existence so there's an existential
aspect to it that's also quite similar
to what's going on in lacanian
psychoanalysis by the way
we can go on a little bit further and
talk
about this this two-part study that he
he tells us that that we need to engage
in
a psychoanalytic interpretation of the
life experience of the black man
and a psychoanalytic interpretation of
the negro myth which is being carried
out in here by talking about
negrophobia and other aspects of
culture through representation right he
also talks about
uh carrying out an analysis of the real
and he says it's always difficult as an
investigator
we can choose between two attitudes we
can be satisfied only to describe
or once we've described reality we can
make up our mind to
change it so he wants to produce
interventions ultimately that would be
changing things
both for individuals and for the larger
dynamic finally i think that one of the
things that's really important in here
is fanon at a number of different points
says that the responses that that black
subjects are having
are in some respect rational and normal
within an abnormal situation of
colonialism racism economic exploitation
all of those sorts of things we can pick
out a few
examples of him bringing this up he says
going up against something unreasoned
psychoanalysts say nothing is more
traumatizing for the young kid
than his encounters with what is
rational i would personally say
that for a man whose only weapon is
reason there's nothing more neurotic
than contact with unreason
you know the the dynamics that we
experience
of injustice of unfairness
of you know intransigence on the part of
this this entire world
that will take a rational person and
make them seem to be
irrational i think maybe one other prime
example would be
be good here he says that
here we go talking about about
children and and families
says a normal negro child having grown
up within a normal family will become
abnormal on contact with the white world
why because of its fundamental
irrationality and it's forcing people
into categories
that really don't fit them well and
require a deformation
on their part if they're going to fit in
or sometimes even survive
so a lot of discussion here of
of how psychoanalysis plays out in this
very uh you know penetrating work
i've actually only kind of scratched the
surface and i
you know i always say this with these
core concept videos it's very important
to read the text
and so you know if you do that you're
going to go beyond what we've got
here and see yet more discussion of
psychoanalysis but in order to keep it
relatively short and self-contained
we're going to end here
you